i was i i screamed holy crap uh
that was unbelievable just to see the
way he tossed that guy that was probably
one of the meanest stiff arms i've ever
seen
no doubt i've been doing too many curls
so i gotta lay out the arms
yeah i don't think derek henry
has to worry about losing any strength
whether he lays off the curls or not the
guy
is chiseled out of granite and he put
josh norman down on the ground
in a way that you rarely see one grown
man
do to another and josh norman is not
small
no he's not a six quarter you're right
yeah and and
down he went and down went the buffalo
bills and who would have seen this one
coming the tennessee titans
with 16 days between games manhandling
the buffalo bills 42 to 16
sending the bills to the first loss
we're going to be talking about that and
plenty more the show is pro football
talk live
hello to our audience on peacock sirius
xm211
the re-air on nbcsn at 9 a.m eastern
where
at least 90 percent of what you will be
seeing and hearing is still
fresh and 7 o'clock local time uk and
ireland sky sports nfl great to be with
everyone also the podcast audience which
gets very miffed yeah if i don't mention
them hello podcast audience
we hear you we see you not really
but we care yes
we definitely care about the bills chris
because
they got a problem after last night my
god how
what in the world happened to your boy
blue
and the rest of his teammates it was uh
an off night i mean first off
i think the the first thing that needs
to be talked about is what you started
off saying
the the tennessee titans i mean that was
pretty unbelievable
just to come out there and play like
that without practicing doing that
you know football is just not one of
those sports that
you can usually pull that off to where
you can play a game and not have
mistakes and
execute the way they did i mean we
didn't see
really blown coverages or you know
missed assignments as far as missing a
run block or
pass protection i'm amazed by that and
then i think what also
made the game you know even more in
favor of the tennessee titans is yes it
was an off night from
for josh allen and the buffalo bills i
mean across the board hey
first series of the night you know he
throws a ball is it perfect no but the
receiver's got two hands on it
interception
you know next series punnett big punt
return
short field tennessee titan so it was
all over it was penalties it was drops
josh allen made some stupid plays
himself the defense
which we've talked about a little bit is
is being exposed to a degree
and i think there's some issues there
that we need to talk about
but i still think the big story of the
night yeah it was disappointing buffalo
we were expecting a better game
and a better showing from them but man
i'm just i can't get over mike vrabel it
just it speaks to him and how he kept
the team together
and the guys he's got in that locker
room for them to go out there and play
like that i'm pretty amazed by it
and it really is impressive how the
titans found a way
to turn everything that's been going on
for the last 16 days
into a point of motivation and that
speaks
to great coaching great coaches can
find anything and they'll make something
up if they have to it's the michael
jordan approach
and they'll convince themselves it's
true even if it's not in this case
the criticism of the titans and we saw
flashes of it when ryan tannehill spoke
to the media over the weekend
there was some of that frustration
starting to come out and in hindsight i
wish i'd have looked at it and said
there's your clue that they're getting
themselves
riled up and ticked off over the fact
that so many people are saying you guys
broke protocol
you guys aren't buttoned up you guys
were practicing when you shouldn't have
practiced
you guys have done a lot of things you
shouldn't have done now here's the
reality
most of that was coming from the league
telling all the other teams
what they were going to do to the titans
we'll talk more about that coming up
later in the program
but we were all pre-positioned to think
that the league was going to hammer the
titans
and that's what created this sense that
everyone's wagging their finger at the
titans
and they used that to get themselves
pissed off at the world and whatever it
takes
to do what they did last night 42 to 16
whatever it takes
do it bottle it hope it's still there
every week for the rest of the season
because that's the kind of thing that
can carry you to a special season i have
a feeling it's not going to last
but they made the most of it their
toughest game so far they were not
impressive in their three wins against
teams that all
aren't very good they play an undefeated
team and they mopped up the floor with
them chris yeah i mean
you know mopped up the floor i do think
the score is a little misleading but
either way they took their souls out at
the end of the game and stomped on it to
make sure you knew who the boss of that
football game was
right i mean they really did and yeah i
mean
motivation all that stuff sure i get it
i'd be doing the same thing
and yeah i was mad at the tennessee
titans i mean i think you were too
we we heard they were being careless i
think that bothered us
um also though i defended them when it
came to practice and doing those things
what do you expect them to do right we
knew with they knew they were going to
be held accountable to what we saw on
tuesday night no matter what whether it
was practice
in the facility whatever so they did
that hey
it's cool it's amazing that they find
that motivation and vrable's great at
pushing the buttons and doing all that
i just still the fact that they pulled
it off
and no turnovers and things like that
where buffalo looked like they were the
team that hadn't practiced and done
meetings and things like that
i think that was shocking to me mike and
then you know i think the other thing
that
that i looked at more than anything i
mean vrabel he's
he's he's awesome as far as
game plan specific things he does on the
defensive side of the ball and i'm
excited to watch that film but
you know facing off against brian davall
who has that new england system of
course vrabel knows it very well had
success against josh mcdaniels two years
ago
and even last year in the playoffs of
course so i think they did some things
that probably other teams haven't done
to buffalo i'll be interested to see
what that is
uh and i don't know if you heard my dad
at halftime
i just the first thing that jumped out
to me in the game was how much bigger
tennessee
was than buffalo i mean tennessee just i
mean
you kind of said it derek henry was
looks as big as the defensive lineman on
buffalo
that was concerning to me where i you
know if you think about buffalo being a
big-time playoff super bowl contender
and made me think twice a little bit
about them
especially the way they looked up front
on that defensive side of the ball
well derek henry didn't have a huge
night from a yard standpoint he did have
a huge night from a
putting a guy on his rear end standpoint
and it gave that team a lift
and sean mcdermott after the game the
coach of the bills
repeatedly said they beat themselves i
watched all of his press conference
before the show they beat themselves
he wants to give credit to the titans
but they beat themselves poor discipline
poor pre-snap
discipline poor fundamentals poor with
the turnovers
and you're just not going to win a game
like that and he didn't see it coming he
didn't expect it he makes no excuses
for the uncertainty that hovered around
the game
but at the end of the day his guys
weren't ready
the titans were ready and it showed and
one thing that mcdermott kept mentioning
the inability of the front four to
create pressure
and of course that's a problem going
into their next game
monday night against the chiefs team
that's coming off of a loss
that's going to be as desperate if not
more desperate than the bills all of a
sudden that monday night
first half of the doubleheader with two
4-0 teams that are now four and one
and then have extra urgency to avoid
going to four and two
is huge chris and and because the bills
looked so bad defensively last night
relative to what we expect
they got to get this fixed and they have
one less day
to do it than they ordinarily would have
had because they had to play tuesday
night they got to turn around and play
on a monday yeah i mean
the defense is an issue i i don't think
there's any doubt about that you know we
saw it kind of rear its ugly head
against the los angeles rams right you
know
we saw them run the ball and gash
buffalo at certain points of the
football game
the raiders had success too now the
raiders what hurt them too
is the fact that they were missing some
receivers in that game and that allowed
buffalo to crowd the box a little bit
more than
maybe they would have been able to if
henry ruggs was out there and everything
like that
but last night i mean yeah they have a
real issue
they can't get pressure on the
quarterback with four
and the other thing they're doing is now
they're always blitzing five or six guys
and you see how open the middle of the
field is and some of the throws ryan
tannehill makes i hate that approach
i hate the five and six man blitz i'd
rather you go the opposite do what
tennessee did to josh allen you see
they were russian three and russian two
and doing stuff like that
that's that's the way to go there but
ultimately
mike this is they have a flaw in their
defensive scheme in buffalo
too many plays end up back on the plate
of number 24 tyron johnson too many
and he's the nickel cornerback right and
i'm talking about run game and
pass game mike where i find it all my
teachings from john gruden
and josh mcdaniels and people where okay
they're playing this defense
what's the flaw to this defense too many
of the times
he's put in the position to be the flaw
whether it's the run game or covering aj
brown with no
help around him and aj brown just gets
to run across the field and that's
something they're gonna have to fix up
that's cool if you want to play that
defense but then you better have jamal
adams or derwin james play in that
position
not tyrone johnson so they got to get
some things figured out because their
defenses uh
has not looked good really the whole
year yeah all it takes is one week link
like that that gets exploited over and
over and over again until you do
something about it the team
is not going to feel sorry for you that
they have found a weakness
in your secondary and they're going to
continue to throw in that direction
until
something is done to improve it we put
up a
graphic earlier and and this just puts
into context how impressive it is what
the titans did
first team to score a touchdown on every
red zone possession with a minimum
of six of them have zero turnovers allow
no sacks
since the patriots beat the bills 56-10
in week 11
of the undefeated season of 2007 and of
course
mike vrable coach of the titans for this
attempt
was a member of the patriots when they
did it to the bills and the poor bills
on the wrong end of the last two times
it's happened now it's a very specific
stat it's like every week you find some
specific unique thing
that's never happened before but that's
still impressive
very for the first time in 13 years to
see that kind of performance that kind
of red zone efficiency it speaks to the
failures of the bills because
that's the area where number one it
should be easier to defend because you
don't have to worry about
anyone getting behind you it's all
packed in and number two the stakes are
higher
far higher than they are when you're on
the other 20-yard line yeah you're not
used to seeing
those type of issues with a buffalo
bills defense or a sean mcdermott
defense i mean the one thing that's been
very consistent since he's took it over
taking over there is their defense has
played sound and been a pain in the butt
for everybody
and we are seeing issues across the
board there and yeah the tennessee
titans
you know first off they got the short
field you know that was the one big
thing
but they're they're where they're weird
is they're a big play football team
i mean that's the one thing i think as
i'm sitting there watching the game last
night too i'm going you know i don't
give them enough credit for that
they they really are we think about them
as this ground and pound ground and
pound
but you know turnover margin number one
in football
explosive plays i think they're number
one in football or they're towards the
top of the league or something like that
and that's because ryan tannehill never
leaves any yards out in the field i mean
as you saw last night
if there's a 40-yard completion to be
had and the guy's opened by three inches
he throws it in there and it's a 40-yard
completion same with the touchdowns
they're aggressive that way and they
look to make those type of plays and
it's why
between their game plan specific and
then their aggressive nature really on
both sides of the ball that's why
they're made for playoff football and
they're going to be a pain in the butt
this whole year
uh if they continue to kind of play the
way they did last night and wipe away
some of those early season struggles we
saw
ryan tannehill was a top 10 pick back in
2012 the year andrew luck was the first
to ever see
back the year that russell wilson
arrived in round three
and what happened is i believe the
narrative around ryan tannehill
has been so baked into the dna of the
football fan
and the person who covers football
that's right that we resist
what is before our very eyes and that is
a guy
who is becoming or has become
an elite quarterback chris last night
21 for 28 195 yards three touchdowns
no picks passer rating of 129.3
he added 42 yards rushing on four
attempts with a touchdown
he's smart about when he runs he's fast
when he decides
to roll out of the pocket he's not
rolling he's sprinting out of the pocket
i mean this guy can move
and i'll i'll stand by what i said
earlier this year
he looks different he does he just
there's something about him and maybe
he's just
filled out after eight years in the nfl
but his neck is
thick and his jaw seems more you know
protruding like he's just
it's like he went from being clark kent
to superman at some point over the last
eight years am i wrong
well he i i when you said there's
something different
i take it more as like there's just this
confidence and calmness about him ever
since like week 12 last year where you
just feel like
they show the camera and big situations
and he just kind of has that look in his
eye where you go
he's not even the slightest bit bothered
or flustered or
actually seems quite confident i mean
there was a shot on him last night and i
think a second down play
he was smiling as he was underneath the
center it looked like some linebacker
was talking trash to him
and he was kind of laughing and giggling
about it so that just tells you how
in the moment he is and that the game
has slowed down
and as we've always talked about you can
be a really really good football
player and be stuck in a bad situation
or not have the support around you that
can ever
show or accentuate the great things you
have
about your ability if you're stuck in
the wrong situation
and like we saw with minka fitzpatrick
in the miami dolphins now he's one of
the best safeties in football goes to
pittsburgh
well here we go ryan tannehill same kind
of thing got put with the right support
got a right the right game plan and
system around him
and now he's taking full benefit and
hopefully people are opening their eyes
to go damn
this guy is a top 10 quarterback in
football i mean it's
it's really kind of impossible to deny
at this point after the last you know
year or so and this cuts against the
trend that we've seen in the nfl
in recent years really for the last 20
years where you expect the guy to figure
it out
right away and if you don't you're
thrown to the curb
this is a guy who was a receiver at
texas a m he played quarterback for one
year
before the joe philbin dolphins made him
a top 10 draft pick in 2012.
and he was starting to come into his own
in 2016 with adam gase until he takes a
low hit from calais campbell
the acl is compromised it's
partially torn well it's not going to
heal itself they made the fateful
decision not to get it repaired after
the 2016 season
training camp 2017. there it goes
and there it went for ryan tannehill in
miami
and now it's amazing to think what the
dolphins had they had to pay part of his
salary yeah to unload him onto the
titans
right and you know remember when marcus
mariota does the start it's like oh ryan
tannehill i mean marcus mariota is the
starter well i mean you you saw it from
the get-go
hey marcus mario's not gonna be the
starter for very long if ryan tannehill
can figure things out
and it's just amazing what he's done the
last two years and it's amazing what
this titan is you know we see the
nikification of the nfl and i'm not
that that should have been on the pft
bingo card my reference to
the constant uniform changes made by the
nfl now
but you know this is proof that
a good team can make a bad uniform
look a hell of a lot better and man
those titans uniforms are looking damn
good right now aren't they well they got
a little bit of an
aura and a toughness to them like you
know i don't know what it is
i i was not in favor of like the all
blue helmet i i was
on a tennessee titan team for two it's
like a bowling ball right it looks like
a bowling ball it does where are the
holes
it looks like a bowling ball and the
fact that it looks like it's covered 19
on the side right now is not a good look
for them either i mean it's kind of a
double whammy it became a
nfl meme there for a little bit but uh
there's there's an aura there about just
a big tough
physical team and when they wear that
all blue or whatever
they just look kind of mean and tough
and then hey they're head coaches
meaning tough
and that's the way they play they got an
attitude about them
they don't blink ever they're always
physical
they're creative sometimes they mess
some things up as we've seen in the
first few weeks to where
you know they blow a gasket because
they'll do one week cover three's this
the next week cover three is a wholly
a totally different type of coverage
because we made it more specific to this
game plan and they
they mess things up but i think as the
season goes and the more this team plays
together and gideon clowney keeps coming
along and all that
um they're a team that i think i
probably even undersold
early in the year where i go uh oh they
might be one of the best teams in the
afc there's no doubt
well they were a final four team last
year and right now they're 4-0
for the second time in franchise history
the other time the tennessee titans were
4-0
christopher davidson i was there as a
member of the roster and that was the
year
that came down to that december game i
think it was a saturday game wasn't it
it might have been
titans yeah steelers it titans and
and the one seed is riding on it and the
titans win
and it was keith bullock and glendale
white
desecrating the terrible towel and and
that
curse like stuck to the titans for
several years i think they ultimately
had an
exorcism or they made a donation to the
to the
whatever the charity is that benefits
from the proceeds of the terrible towel
they desecrated the terrible towel and
hovered over that team for several years
uh and started with that loss to the
ravens in the divisional round
oh uh which was it was a stunner i mean
the tigers were one of they were one of
the best teams in football
that year who ended up winning the super
bowl that year the steelers
i know yes damn steelers won it right
and you know yeah we played them in a
week 15 game and i was just sitting over
there holding the clipboard
uh but that was the best football team i
was ever on i think you've heard me say
that before
it was albert haynesworth was arguably
the best defensive player in the game
keith bullock was phenomenal we had
cortland finnegan and
and michael griffin at safety we had a
lot of good football players let alone
cj2k
and carrie collins and kenny britt and i
mean uh that was a heartbreaker for me
that really was uh but but uh definitely
this team looks like it could rival that
team a little bit
did you have any role or responsibility
in the desecration of the terrible tower
yes or no absolutely did you try to stop
it did you try to stop it no
there's no stopping those guys on that
team
and i was the new guy on the team i
certainly wasn't gonna be able to stop
it
you know that that was a fun team
lindell and keith bullock and then we
had some personalities and uh i
certainly wasn't gonna get in the middle
of it
let's flip it over to your boy blue yeah
josh allen give him a letter grade for
last night
oh probably i'd say a
c somewhere in there maybe a c plus
something like that no
plus he say plus he had something you
know let's see pluses
no you know that reference no what is
that that's the that's the great ralph
he got on his paper where he tried to
make the argument to his teacher that
he should get a red rider carbine action
bb gun i got you i remember that
stock and this thing that tells time he
got a c plus right one of the great
lines one of the great lines
and this is american literature i don't
think a football is a very good
christmas present that was one of the
lines
plus paper yeah all right go ahead sorry
they're wrong about that one it's a
grateful difference
but i got a c plus but my boy blue
i mean yes you know was not his best
night i mean even you know like we
talked about the first interception was
not his fault
it was not but he threw it you know a
little behind andre roberts
roberts had two hands on it but we
haven't even really seen that type of
stuff from
josh allen every throw really the whole
year has kind of been on the money
so between that the really bad
interception
to malcolm butler where i don't know if
he didn't see him and he was blinded
or someone that was a bad one and of
course that [ __ ] set up the short field
for the tennessee titans too
but the drops and then hey there was a
few
that i'm gonna put the drops on josh
allen and i don't say this much
but there was a few throws where he just
threw the ball too freaking hard
like there was a few throws over the
middle that were eight and 10 yards
and he just unleashed it and it went
through stefan diggs hands one time and
another time through
dawson knox hands where i think they
looked at him they were just like
you threw that it was 145 miles per hour
and i was seven feet from you
you know so i think he got a little
excited and flustered about the
situation the defense they were playing
all of that certainly not his best night
and uh the team around him didn't help
him a whole lot either
you know that's an amazing human reality
of situations like that you get
frustrated it manifests itself in
different ways you try to do too much
and you just you know you're mad about
the way things are going
and you just throw the football a little
bit harder just because you're mad
right it's all part of the challenge of
channeling and and harnessing and
controlling your emotions
sometimes you can sometimes you can't
and that's one of the
one of the criticisms sure right and and
he's
blamed himself for the emotion that came
out as the
lead 28-3 the most dangerous lead in
football was disintegrating for the
bills against the rams he got emotional
he drew a penalty
uh for uh unsportsmanlike conduct for as
he told me afterwards using some bad
language to the
the ref that he shouldn't have used and
and uh you know
look football's an emotional game i
don't know how you turn it off
when you're out there and you're getting
hit and you're getting chased
and things are happening and guys are
yelling at you and they're talking crap
and you're still
young you how can you turn it off we saw
tom brady 43 years old blow a gasket on
thursday night
right you can't turn that off no it is
it's tough to turn off
it's it's it's something again that
hopefully he learns from we've seen him
learn from everything so far to where
the next time he's in that moment he can
you know whatever you have to do take a
deep breath realize okay yeah we're down
21-10
it's not the end of the world we'll be
okay we're still in this
you know it just it just i i think
compounded itself a little bit last
night i think it was the first game
where
the whole year they were a little bit
like wait where's our 30 and 40 yard
completions at
like so i think they all got frustrated
they're like what we got to throw the
ball
six yards again i mean they nobody's
done that to them this year
so i think that led to the frustration
as well and we saw tennessee with all
these three-man rushes dropping people
and doing all that
the other thing buffalo has an issue
buffalo can't run
they can't run the football so when a
defense plays like that
they got to have something there you
know and and they're they're missing
their
zach moss who they drafted in the fourth
round who i think is a really good
running back but you see last night
like yeldon and singletary hey they're
solid
but they leave a lot of meat on the bone
especially singletary and that's why
they drafted zack moss and that's just
that's another aspect of that team that
i'm shocked by
because just mcdermott his first few
years was all about run and play defense
and it's just totally flipped 180 here
this year to where it's
no defense we can't run the ball and
we're awesome at throwing the ball and
we're kind of like the greatest show on
turf type of team right now which uh
you know i just i find it amazing about
a sean mcdermott team
yeah and uh tj yelton had seven carries
52 yards last night
singletary 11 carries for 25 and josh
allen added 18.
yeah look that's that's that's not the
way to win football games you can't rely
on your passing game you can't be one
dimensional you have to be able to
establish something
uh with the running game and uh you got
to have the
the horses to take advantage of whatever
is there
um the bills now how concerned are you
what's your level
one to ten well ten being the most i
think the i mean
no i i'm still like if ten's the most
concerning
i'm about a five but i i think the thing
i look at
a little bit with them right now that
kind of just hit me last night where i
just go
okay i i i think they're gonna have to
they're gonna really have to win with
their offense every week i kind of kept
thinking maybe the defense would come
around and they'd figure it out
but we talked about you know lack of you
know marquee pass rushers
d lyman in general nobody making plays
ed oliver has been a disappointment as a
top 10 pick from the 2019 draft
you know we didn't really hear any of
the big players names last night of
course trudeau's white was hurt but
i'm just concerned that it seems like
every game
is going to be like hey josh allen
you're going to have to win it and it's
going to be about our passing game
and us doing that and uh that is where
it could be fun
it can be great and they're gonna get in
the playoffs
but i just don't know if they can win a
super bowl or get to a super bowl that
way
with the way this team looks right now
yeah and they still have to deal with
the patriots twice
and before that they have to deal with
the kansas city chiefs
the seahawks are there the steelers are
waiting for him the 49ers are waiting
for him so they got they got a long road
ahead of them still here
steelers titans the last two undefeated
teams in the nf
in the afc and one of the reasons that
they are the last two
their week four game wasn't played
that's coming up in a week and a half
steelers titans they may still be
the only two undefeated teams in the afc
when they get together
uh in week seven so some good stuff
coming up you mentioned the malcolm
butler
interception right it was a 68-yard
return according to next-gen stats
malcolm butler traveled 101.8 yards on
the play the most
in-play distance traveled on an
interception return this season
and you know you talked earlier about
the past that carried off the hands of
andre roberts and you know john brown
wasn't there last night trudeau's white
wasn't there
that's right i think it hurt the bills
to not have that key piece on either
side of there no doubt
no doubt you're exactly right i mean
it's just one less matchup tennessee had
to worry about at the wide receiver
position
that's the beauty of buffalo you know
yeah okay yo you stopped diggs you
stopped beasley
well john brown's over there he's got a
favorable match up you're just hard to
match up with them all across the board
let alone even if you want to play those
deep dropping zones
john brown shallow crosses things like
that he's very good at catching those
type of balls and
you know turning it up field for for
gains that way and we know treydavious
white is their best corner that's
that's that's an issue in buffalo you
know as you can see they're not real
deep
at the corner position and he's really
their only
marquee corner they got to play a guy
like aj brown or
another big time receiver so um yeah
they were not at their best
i think if they played again you know i
i don't think that the results would be
the same
i think this game i still think if they
played again and you know
buffalo is a little bit more on their a
game
that this would still be a very close
football game and i still have
confidence that buffalo would be able to
move the ball on them if that full
strength and healthy
let's get back to the point we made
earlier about the motivation that the
titans have somehow found
and all of the criticism that they've
been taking publicly for their
apparent violations of the covet 19
protocols here's ryan tannehill
after the game talking about how they
use that as a source
for anger frustration and ultimately
preparation
we're under a lot of heat um honestly i
didn't quite understand it
for you know why we were we were under
such such heat
you know personal things were set
against our team our guys
and um really felt uncalled for so
yeah we were a little ticked off about
how we've been treated have been looked
at over the past couple weeks and
um really just stuck together through
that process and
and believed in each other and wanted to
come out and and play our game and play
how we believe in each other and knew we
could do we did that
they hated him they were angry at us
they thought we did everything wrong
don't put us in adversity scratch all
day match on late
[Applause]
that was first ryan tannehill and then
taylor lawn i don't know what personal
things were said who was saying
personally
because it we definitely would have
written about it at pft
we like it when it gets personal
personal sells i think they got
probably the backlash for people saying
they were being selfish by having the
workouts and doing that
and i i'm guessing that just i don't
know if i necessarily saw like articles
or things like that that attacked them
personally but you know when you look at
comments
and things on social media you know
people got them that way i guess that's
what they're doing we don't pay
attention to those things we don't
listen to the outside noise
except when we can use it to our benefit
to get us all
juiced up and fired up and ready to go
play that's when
that's when mike rabel prints them out
and staples them to the wall of the
locker room so we can all see what
people are saying
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports